so before he robbed the rich and gave to
the poor he was downright a badass Robin
Hood
yeah there's no subtext okay so it's
been 19 years since we've seen Robin
Hood movie or 17 yeah 17 and let's face
it it was just a matter of time before
we saw a remake in a story of Robin Hood
but the director of gladiator gives it
to us but keep in mind this Robin Hood
is an origin story so that hole robbed
from the rich and give to the poor thing
that doesn't really go down in this
movie but I'm pretty sure it's saved for
a sequel now what I really liked about
this version is pretty much but I can
guarantee a lot of people are gonna hate
about this version that's a much
different take on the characters I mean
let's face it we all know the story of
Robin Hood so when you're all out there
thinking yeah okay I've seen Prince of
Thieves I know exactly how the story's
gonna play out yeah you should probably
think again this Robin Hood takes
everything you think you know about
Robin Hood from seeing that Costner
movie and takes a [ __ ] in your front
yard in a good way I mean you see the
characters that you remember from Prince
of Thieves but it's a totally different
take on them and I for one found that
refreshing I mean at a point early on in
the movie it was clear that I did not
know how this movie was gonna play out
anymore I mean and that's awesome I was
in new territory now I mean for one the
Russell Crowe Robin Hood isn't that true
blue white knight serving a King Richard
that you remember him being I mean the
guy gets home from the Crusades and
you're supposed to go live his life and
then he just runs into some [ __ ]
yeah and Maximus Meridius just isn't
having that but there's kind of more to
it than that I just can't tell you about
it but I mean how this guy becomes the
Robin Hood is really cool the scene it's
not all cut and dry like um ha my
father's dead Oh
Benjen I swear it on my own blood and
why do I have a watch in like the second
century yeah the angle that Ridley Scott
comes from in this movie makes for a
much cooler backstory - Robin Hood
I mean honestly simply speaking if you
liked Kingdom of Heaven and you want to
see that style applied to the Robin Hood
story there's no real reason why you
shouldn't like this movie but it doesn't
concentrate on Robin Hood's friends as
much as I would have wanted it to but it
does concentrate on Robin Hood which is
kind of the point and it does touch
heavily on the politics of running a
bankrupt country from King Richard's
crusade and a country divided from its
new douchey King I personally thought
the story was really well thought out
and although it doesn't touch on the
whole robbed from the rich and give to
the poor thing that people really know
Robin Hood for that's pretty much set it
for the sequel I thought it was great I
mean by the end of this movie you
realized that the story
Robin Hood is just too big for one movie
and how badass would that be to have
this sweet war epic Robin Hood trilogy
all Ridley Scott style tell me that
wouldn't be awesome so personally for me
Robin Hood was the stuff that medieval
political war epic should be made of so
go check it out it was medieval badass
[Music]